comme c'était effrayant ce n'était pas prévu
nous sommes prévenus mais nous n'attendons pas mais
fort correspond à la vérité que
et exploser a été bien la première fois
ils étaient encore à la lumière
orange qu'ils ont dit et d'autres si vous savez
ils ont beaucoup remarqué plusieurs tremblements
tremblements mais depuis le
travail orange parce qu'on n'imaginait pas
que c'était si soudainement
simplement pour compléter ce qu'ils ont
tant dit le président qui a
il y avait comme le président des îles canaries
nous sommes évidemment très conscients de
les incendies qui peuvent survenir
à la suite de l'éruption, ils laissent
déployer non seulement la garde civile
que la police nationale est déjà là aussi
équipement de lutte contre les incendies de forêt
extinction du gouvernement des îles canaries
[Musique]